for Charlie McLean the death of her son
Kyrie meant she lost the most important
thing in her world today the two
teenagers who murdered him were given
life sentences
in a statement read out on her behalf
outside of court she simply asked why
I now ask myself what has this achieved
what has my son died for
nobody has won in this situation I have
lost a child and other parents have lost
two children who have been who committed
this offense and are now in prison
this violence has to stop
fifteen-year-old jacobusey was sentenced
to a minimum of 17 years in prison
seventeen-year-old Giovanni Harriet
sentenced to a minimum of 18 years
heard how the pair lame wait for Kyrie
outside his school in black clothes and
balaclavas for a pre-planned attack that
saw a 30 centimeter blade plunged into
his chest
outside the gates the ties Trinkets and
tributes are reminders of how the victim
was still a student
the killing of a 15 year old in broad
daylight as he walked home from school
shocked his friends family and The Wider
Community here in Huddersfield it's also
raised questions about an increase in
knife crime across West Yorkshire
AJ who goes to the same school says it's
violence that is now commonplace
everyone wants to carry a knife for
protection around here like I know a lot
of people do but again like you know you
just gotta constantly look over your
shoulder even though I'm not involved in
you any every any of that obviously I
come here as well
but still you just you don't feel safe
no more
at this Boxing Club they've made it
their mission to address the issue it's
one close to home Kyrie trained here
briefly before he died I've lost four
children now I've dealt with the last
four years to knife crime
um Kyrie came here as part of the school
initiative we hope that we put on and it
breaks my heart
for a mother this loss has left the hole
that will never be filled
it's always those lives that have been
devastated to bring the cruelty of knife
crime into Focus shinki marike Sky News
leads Crown Court